okay so that's the second order cross
partial and so I simply defined this
quantity this way you would work that
out if that quantity is positive and
this is the second derivative with
respect to X if that's positive then the
function has a relative minimum at that
point okay if that quantity D is
positive and the cross and the second
second partial derivative with respect
to X is negative then it has a relative
maximum okay if this quantity is
negative then this has neither a
relative maximum nor a relative minimum
at that point it could be a saddle point
okay and if it's zero then we actually
don't know anything about that those
critical points okay and this is sort of
a pathological case where the crowd
these quantities are exactly offsetting
that quantity which would be unusual
okay
okay so that is that's everything on
multivariate calculus that is
multi-varied certainly the
differentiation side we're going to jump
into integration and summation in a
second but before I do that how is
everyone feeling comfortable okay you're
ready to jump into a integration okay so
there are two fundamental calculus
problems that people for millennia have
been trying to solve and have succeeded
in solving of course but with calculus
but the two fundamental problems are one
to express the slope of a nonlinear
function okay or find the slope of a
curve at a particular point so that's
what we've been doing till now the other
related problem in calculus is to find
the area under a curve okay and it turns
out that the problem of finding the area
under a curve is actually related to the
problem of finding the slope of a curve
at a particular point okay so whoops
sorry so finding the area of a region
under a curve how has it been done in
the absence of calculus well you could
draw the curve for example
this curve here
you could draw this curve and you could
approximate the area under this curve
for example simply by drawing a whole
bunch of actually the way a better
approximation would be excuse me
is to take a bunch of rectangles that
approximate the area under that curve
you know how to compute the area for
rectangle it's simply the length times
the width so you'd work out the area of
each rectangle and then some the area's
over all those rectangles right so you
could certainly do that and that was the
method by which the the definite and
indefinite integrals were actually
arrived at summing these areas is known
as a remind them okay Riemann sum and it
turns out that the integral or the
antiderivative is simply the limit of
the sum of these rectangles as the width
of each of these rectangles goes to zero
so of course if you reduced the width of
these rectangles you'd have many more
rectangles to compute many more smaller
rectangles and your approximation would
get closer and closer to the actual area
under the curve because of course your
errors are all here where you're
estimating too much here too little here
and so on right so the narrower your
rectangle they're more precise your
approximation and if the width of these
rectangles go to 0 then the limit of the
sum of these areas the limit of the
Riemann sum will go to the integral okay
so keep in mind we
talked about the derivative the
derivative itself was a limit that we
were talking about a limit of the slope
of a secant line as the distance as some
increment Delta went to zero okay so
similarly the integral is derived
through a limit okay now so the
derivative was a slope it's the rate at
which the function f is changing with
respect to changes in the variable X the
rise over the run sometimes we know the
rate of change but we don't know the
function itself okay it turns out that
when we do that when when we have that
situation we're really looking for the
integral for a moment let's talk about
the antiderivative think of the
antiderivative not as the integral but
simply as the what you get if you
reverse the process of finding the
derivative right to find the derivative
you applied some rule if you had a
polynomial you used the power function
rule so you had x squared you took the
derivative you got 2x now if you are
faced with some function I want you to
reverse the rules of differentiation to
get the antiderivative the opposite of
the derivative right so suppose FX is a
given function little F X and capital FX
is a function that has little FX as its
derivative can you'll see this often a
capital letter will often denote the
antiderivative function of the little
letter okay so f capital f prime x
is little F X okay so we'll call capital
F the integral or the antiderivative of
little F okay so this is so far we're
just talking in mechanical terms simply
faced with a function you simply reverse
the rules that you use to get the
derivative and by applying those rules
in Reverse you're getting an
antiderivative okay so what's the
antiderivative of x squared you can
reverse the general power you rule if
little F X is x squared then the
antiderivative is going to be well I've
given you the answer there but what's
the logic you applied to get the
derivative to you know if you have some
function X to the K when you take a
derivative you get K X to the K minus 1
okay so you're taking this putting that
in front and subtracting by one so to go
back well you know that you're going to
add one to the exponent okay so if you
had k minus 1 you're going to have K
minus 1 plus 1 okay and what you did
here was you x k multiplied the 10 by K
so you're going to divide by in this
case you're going to divide by the
exponent so you're going to divide by K
minus 1
no because because here just ok so I'm
starting out with this right ok so in
that case we had x squared so suppose
this is x squared then I'm just going to
get you know I'm going to end up with X
to the two and that's k minus 1 plus 1
so i've got x cubed and I've got to /
hold on yeah you I think you're right
right it's got to BK plus 1 because I
had here too that's right sorry this
should be k plus 1 so because it has to
be has to be this and that because this
is what i did when i went down here ok
so in this case k plus 1 is 2 plus 1 so
1 / 1 / k plus 1 which is three ok so
and you can always check if i have to
take the derivative of this well that's
going to be 3 over 3 times x squared
which is just x squared which is what i
had when i started out ok so always do
that check
ok now but the slight complication is
that of course when I take a derivative
if they're happen to have been a
constant in the original equation if
this was X K X to the k plus 2 or X to
the K plus 6 I would still end up with K
X to the K minus 1 so all of those would
give me this derivative so when I
reverse and I go to the antiderivative I
have to keep in mind that whatever I get
as an antiderivative plus some constant
which I do not know it could be because
that it could have been any number that
started out could have been a five or a
one and we denote that the constant of
integration yes yeah I'm just saying
that if you start as suppose you started
out with sorry x to the power of k plus
1 yeah all I'm saying is that I start
your I start out with this and then I
add 12 so so if that's why it's
confusing because it's not that I
started out with k you see that's why we
got where we got confused before I'm
just trying to show you that I go back
to the same place so i'm saying i
started out here with k minus 1 so this
is what i had i just added 1 exactly if
it was K this is what you have to do
this is the rule you have to apply you
just have to add one okay and that's
what I'm doing there I got x squared i
just added one but i have in mind that
that x squared must have come from an X
cubed
my k is yeah that's right my k is no no
no no this is this is a different this
this is a different k right I still have
my k is going to be 3 and I'm definitely
going to get 1 over 3 you see so this
this is the Beast this is the exponent
to which I add one ok and here I've got
some some coefficient it so happens that
those two things are related but I'm
just saying that what's the thing that I
have to do to that to get back here i'm
going to divide by k plus 1 this your
you know what the problem is that the
notation is bad this k is not the same
as that K this K is just is this K right
so that's really this is just a bad bad
way of expressing the notation yes so
instead of x squared let's suppose that
we have 2x cubed ok and that is the
derivative ok so now I know that that's
the derivative so I've got to go up one
so f X has got to have a four ok then
I'm looking for the i'm looking to
divide if i had a 4 here i put the four
there but i ended up with a 2 ok so I've
got to divide let's try that
I do that would that work so that would
be 2x cubed okay but we just have to
make sure I put the four in front I get
a 2x cubed and then plus C okay so you
just I think instead of trying to apply
that rule that I try to come up with on
the fly just ask yourself put the
exponent up by one put that exponent in
front and see what you'd have to divide
by to get that okay is that good
splitter okay yeah so I know you know
one thing that I can be sure about is
that the exponent is always going to go
up by one so first do the exponent and
ask yourself well if I had
differentiated a term X to the 4 that
for would have come in front and it
would have been something like 4x but
actually i have 2x so there must have
been some coefficient that made the four
go to two and what is that what is that
coefficient that i need to make that
four go to two yeah you could yeah you
could take the the this coefficient and
/ yeah which is which was the k plus one
that I had before so / see I put their k
plus one that was the 3+1 but it's a
different k that's why I don't want you
to use that you divide by the new
exponent forget the k but divided by the
new exponent which is which is the old
exponent plus one yeah if you have a
a polynomial function like this okay
won't be the case for example if you had
X in the exponent remember those that's
a different kind of function will see
that in a second okay this see ya the
sea right well the reason for the sea is
that okay if I take a derivative of this
function then as you know you get 2x
cubed suppose that instead of this
function I had the following function
and I were to take a derivative of this
what would be the derivative 2x cubed
right same as before and similarly if I
had 300 there right so there are many
many different functions whose
derivative is this and they're all
different from each other by some
constant and so that C is an indication
of my ignorance that is I do not know
the value of that constant that could be
a 0 or it could be some other number
okay so actually this is really a class
of functions all different from each
other by a constant okay so okay so
let's see so this is suppose you have to
look for the antiderivative 2x minus 1
over x squared so this is a good just to
get some practice okay so
2x minus that's 1 over x squared it's
helpful to write it with the exponent
okay so that's minus X to the minus 2
okay and so what what is f of X well the
2x was what just x squared right so I
raised the exponent by one and then
divided this to buy this too so i end up
with a 1 here and then here I'm going to
raise the exponent by one so that is
minus 1 okay and then divide this
coefficient by that so this is minus 1
divided by minus 1 which is plus 1 ok
plus the constant okay and this as you
know is just 1 over X
okay everybody feel comfortable okay
that's that is the inter indefinite
integral right little F X is a function
whose antiderivative whose anted
actually have written this as
anti-derivatives are big f X plus C a
whole class of functions and how do i
denote this so this is just a notation
I'm sure you've seen this before but
just remind yourself this is a script s
for summation because it an integral is
just a summation over a continuous
interval of f of X DX the D X denotes
the tiny interval of the tiny width of
the imaginary rectangles that you can
think of which you use to construct the
area under f of X okay so the function
inside this script s and D X is the
derivative okay that's what you have to
find the antiderivative off and that is
the antiderivative okay okay you know if
this would be why then it would be with
respect to Y and so on okay here's an
example with here's a useful example
that you might come across so suppose we
determine X to the determine the
antiderivative of x to the r where r is
a constant not equal to minus 1 so
there's just a general generalization of
the problem
we've been doing so far okay so note
that x to the r is the same as X to the
odd times r plus 1 over R plus 1 this is
just equal to 1 so ok so let's it looks
more obvious when you write it this way
x to the r is of course just X to the r
over r plus 1 over r plus 1 ok so again
just using the power rule that we talked
about before this helps us to do the
division of the coefficient that we did
before if I have to find if X to the r
is the derivative the antiderivative is
going to be X to the r plus 1 and then
this has to if I were taking a
derivative this would go in front so
would be an r plus 1 but I have a 1 here
so what I have to do is to / / r plus 1
right so i'm going to get r plus 1 just
as we did before we we take the new
exponent and divide this by r plus 1 it
may not help you to think about it this
way
well you know if you just want to think
about it as take the new exponent and
divide the old coefficient by the new
exponent that's fine okay but here's why
you want to know exactly why here's why
you want to think about this because
you're dividing by r plus 1 right well
what can you not / in our Emma in our
numerical imagination by 0 right so if
our happens to be minus 1 then you can't
carry out that division which is why
we're excluding the case that r is equal
to minus 1 okay that was your question
right anybody know for bonus credit what
the antiderivative is if R is minus 1
yeah it's the natural log right so that
is if R is minus 1 okay that's the same
as 1 over X the antiderivative of 1 over
X is the natural log of X okay and
deriving that is beyond the scope of
this evenings session but just keep that
in mind it is actually something we use
quite a lot in economics the natural log
and its derivative
you